and then you've got but you know Poirier
of course was knocked out by Michael
Johnson and then you've got you coming
off the loss to Tony storm the gates
with this fight and then you've got
Eddie Alvarez who look great against
just engag that it's very hot
yeah and Connors I think that's the
x-factor is what's happened with Connor
yeah I mean dust is out there but I just
don't see no I'm speaking as it from a
fan you know yeah I just don't see no
upside to that you know I mean are you
fighting him no no to him ik Abib I mean
they can make it happen and can people
go out there and he'll smoke them I mean
it would be real here but uh I just
don't see many fans getting behind that
just from what does dust and bring to
the table that could be been already
seen this is the big fight right now I
mean just being completely honest the
big fight right now is khabib and
conversation that's the big fight
whatever big fight or even Madison
Square Garden I mean they they can make
that happen
I don't think mike has ever letting them
I just don't think they're gonna do that
they don't play games men and athletic
commissions a different Commission and
they're new to MMA and that was
embarrassing for them I mean him
throwing the [ __ ] dolly and the fact
that they let them get in there with all
his boys and the whole thing was just so
thuggish he didn't I think in Bellator
happened and was that in New York and
New Jersey what thing happened in
Bellator where he where he went over and
slapped Goddard and all that people they
call people [ __ ] and hoes and it was
that I want to say that was in Ireland
or England was it in Ireland I think it
was in England I want to say it was in
London wasn't that the belt or London
card no no no I don't know but that
Goddard thing's crazy yeah yeah I felt
like that happened on the East Coast too
but I mean if that was one neither way
it's like he just keeps [ __ ] up with
this kind of stuff in and you know no
one's saying get rid of him he's just
he's worth so much money it's really
fascinating what I was saying is imagine
if Rey Borg and him switch sides
if Ray Floyd showed up with all his boys
and was screaming and yelling and threw
a dolly at the wisdom deal it's done
buzz fry yeah ray Paul Daley what Paul
Daley must be at home going
Hey look it's certain things ain't no
certain things that we just can't do you
know sorry until you get to that
stratosphere yeah that Conor McGregor
it's like there's so much money to be
made that's the problem
there's like the rules get bent Paul
Paul Daley was did was throw a punch as
he was Josh Koscheck after it didn't
even connect yeah actually been sorted
out yeah and you even had guys like like
will Brookes kind of got the hammer put
down on him didn't he after he got
knocked out and then pushed the ref I
think was that little Brookes sorry I
don't know you looking at me funny all
I'm thinking right it was somebody you
know he got knocked out and then pushed
the ref right after and it's like they
put a lot on I know it wasn't well books
I'm sorry it was a I know who you're
talking about
god dammit who was that sorry yeah but
you know and they held them against him
and he was concussed you know you know
you barely know where you at Jason hi
yeah that's what it was yeah see a
fighter - he's very good fighter and
what people don't understand is that
once you get knocked out then you come
back you really don't know what happened
you're really out of it yeah who knocked
him out who's thought it was dos Anjos
right yeah yeah where's Los Angeles Los
Angeles
Walter wait debut right no no II had 55
still yeah yeah but again he was a great
fighter I mean it's just certain things
that uh we just can't do Joe we meaning
people of color no Lloyd can do I think
it's people with that east there's a
level to the game where you are so
valuable yeah that you like if Connor
McGregor does a pay-per-view fight
especially if they do you heard all that
crazy nonsense they're gonna do with
McGregor like no shoes and you can
clinch but no kicks and no takedowns no
some if they ever did that great gonna
do just printing money yeah I mean water
percent what's so hard for them to not
take that money but I mean
and I don't hold that against I mean I
always said that about the UFC do you
see about the green and I understand
that in this that's kind of where I'm
coming from it from but you know it's
just consistency yeah well you I think
you just have to realize as a as a as a
black man in America really like there's
two ways to approach the situation you
need to be the victim or you could just
say it is what it is that some
circumstances you know I people just
don't support other black people the way
to Irish support the Irish the Russians
support I mean I'm just being real with
you that's reality is white people in
America don't support white Americans
away the Irish support Conor nobody does
what